In today's video,
we're going to see what happens
if these water absorbing beads
get put into a deep fryer.
[Music]
Guys, oil and water don't mix.
You know that.
But when you heat up the oil,
you can actually get
a pretty explosive reaction
when you add water.
Oil heats up to a temperature
far above that of water.
Water will boil away,
and oil at much
higher temperatures
will still be there frying
and bubbling and boiling.
When you add water into it,
the water will vaporize causing
to expand very very quickly.
And if it's underneath
the oil at all,
it can cause the oil
to get launched through the air
while still at
boiling hot temperatures,
or even on fire.
Well, Orbeez have a lot
of water in them.
They absorb many times
their own weight in water,
and so we wanted to see
what happens if you put Orbeez
into boiling hot oil.
To be safe,
we're going to start out
with just one or two
into the hot oil,
see what happens,
and as we scale it up,
we are going to be moving away.
That's why we're
here at the Dome.
Now, we're going to take the
Orbeez, both of the tiny ones
and the bigger ones,
and we let them absorb
a whole lot of water,
and once they're expanded,
we're going to try putting them
into some hot fry oil.
We can try frying some
that haven't absorbed water too.
Here's the basic idea.
We are going
to take some Orbeez,
and drop them into a deep fryer
just to see what happens.
After that, we're going
to overheat that oil,
drop them in again, and see
if there's anything different.
For our first test,
we are going to take some
of our non expanded Orbeez,
we're going to put them
into a metal cup,
put them into the oil,
see what happens.
I doubt it's going
to be very exciting,
but I'm curious.
[Music]
Not a whole lot as Orbeez go.
We're just going
to see what happens.
This is very hot oil.
You think they're going
to pop like popcorn?
Sounds like popcorn.
Oh, that's so cool.
Wait!
No way.
That one actually
like popped like popcorn.
One single Orbee.
[Music]
Okay, not that bad.
Initially, it hissed a bit,
but didn't do
too much else.
Yeah.
I'm wondering as
it's starts to--
But now yeah...
There you go.
Yeah, Orbee itself is
starting to heat up now.
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
I think our orbee ruptured.
Yeah.
Still a lot of boiling
and bubbling going on.
Okay, I'm not going
to get too close,
but I want to see...
It moved.
Okay, so the whole things
rolled over to the side.
Oh, now we see oil
starting to spread out.
There we go.
That's just one.
So the last one did rupture,
but it was a lot tinier.
So what's this one gonna do?
That's a lot more water.
Okay.
It's gonna take
a little bit longer,
but we still don't want
to be close to that.
Because if it does
happen to explode,
and you know,
oil flies everywhere,
that's gonna hurt.
>> There we go.
>> I think it split.
There we go.
That, that is cool.
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble.
Bubble, bubble,
toil and trouble.
There's still some of it left.
Oh no.
A lot of it left, in fact.
Well, one little orbee
was pretty fun,
and one big orbee
was pretty fun.
I think it's time to upgrade
to a fry basket full of Orbeez.
We've got a lot
of little ones,
and a few of the big ones.
I'm excited.
This is gonna make a mess.
I think it will.
Ready?
Careful.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
It is really mad about that.
[Music]
So it was initially mad,
because when we
lowered it in,
the Orbeez themselves had
water on the outside.
Now, the oil itself is
kind of cooled down,
so they've calmed down,
but as the oil heats back up,
I think we're going to get that.
Some new explosions.
[Music]
Nice.
You can kind of see
that big pink one
in the middle hasn't gone yet.
I want to know
what happens when it does.
[Music]
Yes.
That was about half a cup of oil
that just left the machine.
I fear for our camera.
I fear for our cameraman.
He is getting very brave.
Here's, here's the first
big Orbeez that we fried.
Oh that feels so weird.
It's like breaks apart
very very easily.
Deep-fried non expanded Orbeez.
[Music]
It's just...
It's like plastic.
Well, a form
of plastic, sort of.
When we just did one,
it fell apart so much
that it wasn't even
in the basket anymore.
But it looks
like we still have
some results this time.
At least a larger ones.
The smaller one's
maybe at the bottom.
It's true.
Let's find out.
And also, still orbeez,
still full of water, still oil.
[Music]
I don't think the big ones
have even popped yet.
They have--
Okay, putting them back in.
I want to see that.
It might take
some more time, but...
Well, we put a lot in there.
We cooled that oil
>> down significantly.
>> That's true.
I think we fried
our Orbeez pretty good.
I don't think they're going
to do anything else,
so I think it's
time to scale it up.
The fryer has a limit
to how hot it gets,
and so to make sure we
really get enough heat,
we're going to take it up
to a different level.
We're going to try it
on a propane stove.
Hopefully, that gets hot enough.
If not, we might
use the foundry.
We've got a burner,
this should get our oil
pretty nice and hot,
and then we just got
these rocks here.
Those are just stability
because this can by itself,
I don't trust to
hold everything up,
but the rocks are holding
it pretty nicely in place.
We want that rip roarin' hot.
Ah, hot oil.
So this point,
the oil in the pot is I believe
far higher temperature
than you would ever
fry any actual food.
There's a lot of smoke
coming off of it,
and it's a vegetable oil blend,
which has a pretty
high smoke temperature.
We're going to start
with one tiny orbee first,
and see what happens.
Not that one.
[Music]
Yes.
Oh.
[Music]
Oh, for a second I
thought oil had splashed
and is starting to catch...
[Music]
What is dripping?
>> Oh, whoa, what is happening?
>> I wonder if there's a hole in this bucket.
We've realized that we have
a slight problem.
There's actually a hole
in the bucket that we're using,
and that's super dangerous
with our propane tank
directly underneath it.
So we're going to switch
to our foundry regardless,
little bit safer
in regards to explosions.
So our oil is started
to light on fire,
and it is gorgeous.
Really dancing around a lot.
Now, it doesn't have a lot
of oxygen in there,
which it does still
need to burn properly.
But you can see that
it's starting to pick up more.
As fire comes up out,
it draws more
oxygen down inside.
Okay, that is well
and truly on fire now.
Okay. I'm going to try--
I'm going to try a handful.
Do it.
Ready?
I think we both missed.
Again.
We have more Orbeez.
More Orbeez.
Oh, there we go.
>> I missed again.
>> Farther. Farther.
[Music]
That's amazing.
Big one?
Guys, just remember,
we do have fire
extinguishers on hand.
Lots of them,
and this is
a very fireproof dome.
Like it hasn't really
cause them to pop
like I thought.
No, but they are--
Okay, so when they
are hitting it,
just at the very top,
we are getting
these beautiful sparks.
[Music]
Try one more.
Come on.
[Music]
Oh, well, okay.
>> That just splashed.
>> Yes!
[Music]
Less of a splash.
It's still splashed
some fire out.
I'm just interested,
like it doesn't seem to be
like frying and popping them.
[Music]
That shouldn't be so much fun.
Oh, there you go.
Whoo!
Yikes.
I'm just gonna throw
the biggest handful
of tiny Orbeez.
[Music]
Usually, you're supposed
to hit it.
Guys, you know, we've always
got more for you to see.
That box of the will take you
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other boxes
going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
This bomb in the middle
will subscribe to the channel.
Hit that, joining the club,
never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you soon.